now the coming age of virtual reality
has been buzzed about for years but in
the next few weeks the first
sophisticated consumer devices finally
hit the market one headset in particular
has been scrutinized heavily ahead of a
highly anticipated launch the oculus
rift earlier this week at the Game
Developers Conference I got a chance to
get my hands on one and try oculus for
the very first time so first of all
let's go ahead and get the drift on the
right the left triggers operate the
hands
so you basically it's based on head
control so you look at where you want to
go now go ahead take a look up that's
where you're going hook up with the derp
again and grab it now let go of the
other hand yeah yeah there you go
one hand in front of the other now take
my girl it's no more trips look up hi
there you go first time in what you
think it was great it was great I mean I
really got into it like I feel like I
physically exerted myself my hands are
my hands are tired I'm out of breath